[Music]
[Applause]
he's the u.s
open champ he's the number one rated
golfer in the world he's
john rum joining us on the show john
we want to play a game where is the u.s
open trophy now don't tell us yet okay
let's go around the room where do we
think the u.s open trophy is
at john's home in scottsdale if it's
there
todd i'll start with you he's got a nice
spot for it in the man cave
okay john's got a man cave already all
right
mclovin no i've been where he is there's
baby stuff everywhere it's in the garage
okay all right he does have a newborn
seat no counter
let's say an office home office home
office paulie
new baby hasn't mounted it yet it's on
the floor near his desk in his office
i'm gonna say it's still in the box john
where is your u.s
open trophy well before i say anything
my brother-in-law will not forgive me
if i don't do this so i got to say i'm
63 245.
[Laughter]
and you're wearing a dad bod t-shirt
there exactly
i have the bot i got the dad part now
officially i can wear it
[Laughter]
okay it's actually on the it's in the
living room it's in a little mantel
on top of the fireplace it's the first
thing you see when you walk in the house
well that's pretty good now did you have
to negotiate that with the wife of
i'm going to put it right out there on
display or do you want somebody to
ask for it so they can see it john no
it's actually the only trophy
i have outside the office so everything
else that's in the office
nothing on the man cave which is really
more like a practice area of the house
uh is the only one i have outside would
the baby fit in the trophy
if you wanted to bathe the baby i tried
it doesn't he does not fit he's
not calling he's too big i think if it's
a newborn he would fit but
so when the the top of the the trophy
screws on yeah
he's got this two little things that
come out and could
actually hurt the baby a little bit so i
didn't drive for too long yeah
did you drink out of it yes
what did you drink out of it uh orange
juice oh
of course you do okay all right yeah
yeah that's yeah that's that's what i'll
say in public do you feel different
being the number one player
like being the number one player in the
world or the us open champ which
which affects how you feel as a goal for
more
uh well i had gotten to number one in
the world before so
and i didn't realize until after i won
because i think dustin had to finish i
don't know 19th or wars or something
like that
but when in your first major uh that's
what makes a difference that's uh
a bit of a sense of relief in me
relief a little bit because when you're
number one then they go
uh how many majors do you have or when
when are you going to win a major and
they're guys who haven't won majors who
are
great golfers in history yeah there you
go in golf
when you play good for a little bit you
get put on that best player to never win
a major list very very quick
and to a 26 have gone out of that was
that was a bit of a relief
but is it more mental or physical the
reason why you won the u.s open
mental 100 mental like what kind of
grind was that
it didn't look like it was fun john
[Laughter]
you know when you're playing good it's a
lot more fun than when you're struggling
i had because on saturday and sunday i
played with two guys i played with bob
on saturday matthew wolf and sunday and
they both struggled
so i might be the you know the backlog
term over here and
it just did not look fun while i was
playing okay and
it's a mental stress every single shot
you hit in the u.s open you're stressing
especially and of course like tori pines
so
it's a it's a mental grind that you know
undoubtedly is going to actually
get a little bit of attack on your body
as well but also
you know in a course like that in a
tournament like that par is your friend
but normally you're aggressive and
you're trying to get birdies like
how's the mindset where you go hey i'll
take a four and i'll walk away from here
a lot of times you know you might have a
let's say a doable birdie putt you might
have you know
somewhere around 10 feet or inside 15
feet where you want to make it but you
gotta
understand that hey i made a four let's
move on no matter how it happens right
and
sometimes you're going to make a couple
part putts that feel like they're
birdies or eagles and other times
you know even a bogey part i mean it's
happening to all of us where you make
one good pot and you know you're saving
that one shot
right the key is not giving too many
away you're limited on the amount of
birdies you're going to be able to make
what's the craziest thing you ever
thought of when you're standing over a
putt
craziest thing yeah have you ever
thought like hey i'm thinking about
dinner i'm thinking about no no no no
like have you ever lost concentration
over a putt
i sometimes when i'm playing you know
when you're in a little bit of a zone i
just have a song in my head and
for whatever reason i'll still be
focused on what i'm doing but that's
something we played in my head
and what's the song it all depends it
could be anything honestly being a dad
now a lot of times is baby shark
[Laughter]
how good are you at diaper changing i'm
okay
i'm pretty good i'm uh i've been able to
avoid most of the disasters
both me and my wife kelly didn't never
spend any time around babies right so
early on we had a couple of surprises
especially when you have a boy you have
a couple other things to be you know
yeah you could get it in the eye
it's hit the curtains before
[Laughter]
uh what was a stronger emotion the
excitement of winning your first major
or
when you had to withdraw from the
memorial
oh the excitement of winning my first
major uh withdrawn from the memorial
i think was less of a bother when it
comes to golf
than what most people think just because
you know i tested positive for kovit so
my attention was
automatically on on my family my wife
was asthma her mom has asthma
so i was really worried about that and
in our and our little boys so
i wasn't that worried about golf i never
really
felt any resentment in that sense all i
chose to remember is you know
i played unbelievable golf for three
days um short of the
the guys out there playing really good i
feel like
not that i'm officially the champion but
i would have had a good shot so
you know we'll remember that and i was
just making sure i was
doing everything properly to keep him
healthy and not expect anything in our
family and
so when that's your priority golf was
absolutely secondary
i was mad for you john the way you were
informed
like that it just wasn't fair to you
they could do that privately did anybody
ever apologize to you for that
so the reasoning for that is
because i had tested positive and people
i believe on the broadcast
knew or they were about to find out they
didn't want me to go ahead and shake
anybody's hand on the crowd
or or interact with the crowd uh now
being on the covet tracing list
i had really been like mindful about not
doing any of that
and the only basically moment what i
forgot was after finishing the third
round i had played so good that i
completely forgot
what i had been going through and i
shook my playing partners hands
now both of them had had covet so i feel
like it was okay but
um you know they didn't want me to go in
the crowd and at first i didn't want me
to go inside to sign my scorecard so
it was a bit of a confusing idea and
that's why they told me on the spot
uh now knowing that it's the second time
they put me in a vulnerable spot on
national tv on the same hall on the same
tournament oh boy well
it was it felt a little bit you know
almost more personal but
they did what they had to do and yes the
people in charge did uh
they told me that it could have been
handled better but also
you know i'm i'm listening to faldo and
nance
they didn't know and and they went they
ended their broadcast
and we saw the emotion like i thought
the worst
i thought something had happened in your
family and yeah
i mean i i did react like it i guess
yeah
but at that point had played so good and
you know knowing that it was a
possibility the fact that i had to leave
and
and just everything combined the fact
that my parents were coming in monday
right after the tournament and i hadn't
seen him in a while i think a lot of
emotions got mixed in there together and
it was just upsetting because you don't
expect that to happen right i was the
first one to
through all this to happen and uh
i mean it is what it is i mean my wife
didn't even know very few people know
she thought something happened to my
parents as well so it's uh
yeah i think in that sense is where
things could have handled could have
been handled better
go back to the u.s open and uh phil
mickelson's on the
driving range and i thought that was a
cool moment that
phil was just hanging there just with
your family
yeah he returned the favor i've stayed
i've been
fortunate to be able to stay a few times
to watch him win i did in mexico without
the pga
you know he broke a pretty impressive
record and
he came in and took care of kelly you
know kelly was uh
to say a nervous wreck the least because
he
he was he was stressing and holding the
baby and he was helping her out i mean
they brought some chairs to their range
i don't even know where they got the
chairs from and
he took care of her and and he did an
amazing job you know that shows what a
quality man he is
what did you save from the final round
would i do what what did you save uh
like do you
save anything from the final round and
keep it uh separate
like your score card you get that uh i
don't know if i get that
you don't get the score card i have no
idea i'm thinking the trophy's enough
that's all i'm gonna say
oh well yeah that is good yeah
i mean i was looking for something for
you to donate to the man cave here
john like your socks or shoes or
something
uh my shoes outfit hat glove the usga
took it all for the museum
what i can give you is a yardage book i
used that week i would love that
yeah i do have that that would that
would be awesome uh um
concerns going to the british open
none not really i mean i'm not concerned
about the tournament i'm excited you
know i'm going to a golf course when i
played
lynx golf for the first time that was
about 12 years ago i think it was 2009
and
you know when i got my start on the on
the uk so i would love to to go back and
and uh as the latest champion and
hopefully still is number one in the
world so you know i'm excited to go
really really really here
yeah and you get to uh golfing a sweater
it's uh it's winter time over there in
there
you never know i know this summer one
day it could be freezing the next day
uh but yeah i mean you do get to enjoy
wearing a sweater which
living in arizona is something you miss
i played golf in ireland
in march and it snowed
you can get everything in one day i've
seen rain sunshine not snow but i've
seen hail
wind no wind i mean the weather it's
about as unpredictable as it gets
uh the strangest weather you ever played
in
strangest yeah toughest uh
got a couple amateur events in spain and
severe hail storms
you know when it's amateur events you
don't have you know weather equipment so
you go out there and deal with it
uh i have seen the lightning strike
almost on the golf course
when we were junior players uh and all
sorts of things but
as a pro the craziest happened in
oakmont in 2016 we didn't get to play in
it but the storm that went through
because the goddess of the golf course
is thoroughly enough was about as harsh
as i've seen
well hopefully you'll get good weather
when you go over there and uh congrats
again
uh i love this shirt congrats on being
the number one player in the world and
more importantly
you know you got a baby there and uh
nothing like that every single morning
walk in and see his face smiling can't
have a bad day john
that is true you can't have a bad day
thank you thank you bud that's uh john
rahm
the uh us open champ and the number one
player in the world